but there is a much bigger health risk
in areas affected by Harvey let's go
back to Nora in downtown Houston for
that Thank You Margaret that's right the
devastating flood waters in Texas are
raising several major health concerns
this morning more than 17,000 people are
in shelters more than 8,000 of them are
here in Houston's main Convention Center
health hazards in this disaster are
mounting both in the short and long term
dr. David curse is the physician
director of Houston's
EMS and public health authority doctor
thank you so much for joining us I know
this has been declared a public health
emergency here in Houston when you have
people trapped in floodwaters what's the
big concern well there are a number of
concerns that the person of the meeting
concerns because nobody's gonna be
walking if I'd step on something or not
step on something privets if there's a
manhole cover missing so people gonna be
badly injured walking through the flood
waters it's always dangerous from a
health standpoint we worry about the
organisms that may be in the water and
the chemicals that may be in the water
8,000 people in this convention center
how do you avoid a health crisis when we
have large numbers of people congregate
in small spaces like this you worry
about viral illness outbreaks that would
cause gastrointestinal problems you know
we always heard about the cruise ships
or everybody got sick it's the same it's
the same virus that we worry about on
the cruise ships that we worry about
here the norovirus the norovirus exactly
and that can be a real problem in a
convention center where people are
already you know you've got all kinds of
problems going on you prevent that so
the biggest thing is there's two things
one is we have to really try to get
folks to focus on their own personal
hygiene right so the facility has to
make sure that the bathrooms are kept
tidy so which means they need to be
cleaned multiple times a day so whatever
the routine schedule is facility it
needs to be at least double width in
terms of cleaning also we try to get the
hand sanitizer throughout the facility
so people will have it easily accessible
to them
the one place you don't have hand
sanitizer he's in the bathroom because
you want people to use soap and water to
wash their hands not use the hand
sanitizer because I hope the waters are
much throw more throw clean you know I
well I walk through there I didn't see a
lot of hand sanitizer
so getting the hand sanitizer up and
distribute is been one of our challenges
we need so much of it so the facility
had some to begin with but this is a
crowd that is much larger than the
facility is used to dealing with
especially at no notice it's Texas
there's lots of ants we know that what
about mosquitoes so in the short term
I'm not too worried about the mosquitoes
because all this rain is gonna wash out
all the breeding sites for the
mosquitoes and your average mosquito in
the wild only lives for you know maybe a
week anyways so the pre-existent
mosquito population will drop off and
then there won't be any new mosquitoes
because the larvae all got washed late
but that'll be only about 10 to 14 days
and then we're having an explosion of
mixed mosquitoes because there's so much
standing water which are all which is
all breeding sites so what we deal with
that about two weeks do you have Zika
here we have people who move been here
who have been infected with Zika in
Central and Latin America we've not had
any local transmission here but that is
absolutely something that's front and
center on our radar dr. David purse
thank you thanks to all the doctors and
nurses and health professionals that are
taking care of everybody thank you so
much well thank you for being here